all right so this is old wounds and the
original airbenders
um began two episodes back-to-back of
maybe because of the leak or whatever I
don't know I can't remember anything ran
the back to back
they must have once or twice by all no
feels like in every I think they baby
yeah they ran it back to back like once
or twice then there was like a couple
week hiatus or something or cuz they ran
part of season but anyway we got these
two episodes I'm OCD so I'm gonna move
that a little this way there we go and
this first one the old wounds was that
we find out more about Linda Fong's
background with her sister and why they
had this falling out mostly because the
sister kind of got away with murder and
then the toff had to resign and she
survived her she told no no I'm a murder
but well no grand theft auto yeah and
she she believes it was because of her
and then she never made her mother happy
and she believed she played a part in
that so that's very kind of Lifetime
movie of the week and they finally have
this big confrontation and sure enough
they resolve their differences in a very
not lifetime movie of the week way until
after the very not lifetime will be in a
week wait and then they shake hands yes
she can to play nice and then we have
the other one which is original
airbenders which is ten cent trying to
teach the new airbenders how to be exact
with that Airbender is the romance
between a girl and boy I forget their
names Jinora and Kai them and pretty
much just it's mostly ten to the story
trying to figure I should we be a tough
leader is she be lenient and him and his
brother trying to also comes along yeah
lost separately actually cuz it was also
Jinora wasn't it because she wants to be
considered a master and get a tattoo
which makes him wonder is she gonna get
her head shaved that one no when he said
when he said I'll think about I was
thinking myself the marketing
design team will have a heart attack but
I'll think about my guess would be nice
my guess maybe they'll put it on her
arms or something well we did have one
because one of the avatars was a female
Airbender and you saw it like it was
like half shaved I think like it was
until like the middle of the forehead
then there was an arrow but she still
had long hair so maybe you'll be bad I
don't know I thought I saw one or two
women they had a totally shaved though
too like in the past season somewhere I
don't know no the iliad dressing see
what they do so
yeah both these episodes it's
interesting because the first one I
didn't quite know where was gonna go I
thought maybe it was gonna be something
heavier that happened in the past but
well when you see a scar like that you
have certain ideas about where that came
from and when I finally saw it I'm like
oh well alright not bad but I was like
huh I thought it was like you know
attacked by some sort of super bending
super criminal like their equivalent of
Zod or something and instead it's like
now my bratty sister totally different
when I tried to bust her it's guys it's
kind of like you know Oh India Jones's
scar came from the first time with the
whip like okay you know but just the
whole feud between them - I thought like
it's it's very it's explained but I
thought like man for her not even what
the thought you know like her niece you
know like get out of here like you know
you're offering me peace I tell you to
fuck off I mean it's like I really
thought I was gonna be something even
heavier uh but it's well I guess she was
blaming sue for her mother's early
retirement and years of guilt or some
things yeah especially when you hear
that like the mother even when she
became a cop the mother still never
fully I don't want to say accepted but
still didn't give that big a crap and
you see a little bit of it there you see
even Toph is sort of become like now I
have to work with the system I can't par
the system I can't do this because the
police chief's daughter can't you know
be in prison and this will probably
cause even more it's kind of
actually seeing older depressed talk
it's it's SAP at the same time I'm kind
of like yeah okay that's yeah like still
badass but just like you know the
freaking migraines and the oh my god it
kind of makes sense though it does that
does just it's kind of it's just kind of
sad cuz the last time we saw her well I
guess there was a flashback in season
one but yeah last time we saw her you
know they were all kids and they were
fighting the power and now she is just
the power and well yeah even even before
I mean like you said with the flashback
in season one it's like she'll still
kind of like you know like they can't
get their ways hey we're starting a new
world it's gotta be great in everything
and you know just things get complicated
and when you're in the head of stuff
it's like you become the man you become
the system yeah and it's dealing with
that and yeah and even that counting the
Avatar comic which I'm almost all the
way through the circuit I gotta read the
last one but kind of same thing and I've
read it oh batter patiently um like yeah
it's pretty much like just trying to
figure out you know where do you belong
how much of the system do you become and
how much of a person are you and giving
it since I saw that just in that little
bit that they had of her I thought they
really sort of played that out but
enough about that iron very can I have
another
I always walk more very guy will never
get tired of Merrick I give up things
all this young man that has to come back
yeah yeah yeah I mean I have a feeling
he's gonna be a fight with the criminals
and that I love the ending to with the
she's with the metal clan I want to cut
to the movie theater popcorn everything
this season seems very much build up
where and I get kind of like the first
season honestly where I say you had set
up and then most of it was building I'm
considering the fights we've had so far
though in this yes there's no good fight
it's gonna be pretty epic I think cuz
these are bald like I would think these
are just like the taste
yeah it'll be interesting because
they're still like they're still giving
the action like hey it's still you know
kids you gotta give them their little
fighting and stuff like and they look
great but yeah there's never anything
like huge or gigantic epic yet in terms
of like the characters or the story
because we're still building up our
villains they're still getting their act
together and they all look great I mean
every time I come back to like okay I
love that design love that design love
you know um I don't I always forget it's
like the long-haired guy I'm always like
yeah what's what's he doing please
forget like what do you do because I
read along with their arms off and we're
the third eye Jake about the guy's head
shaved and knows all about airbending
and stuff that's a and there's like that
other guy the long hair guy I'm like
yeah who he his powers are so incredible
that he just he's not even gonna bother
yeah yeah that's right he's just gonna
sit there and just be like it's gone
it's gone
he's you wait what about like my
favorite line in the I think my favorite
line out of all these past two episodes
so far is when he's like you know you've
become a bit of a wise avatar and she's
like conflict resolution it's what I do
and I was like yes no when we is talking
since hey have you ever thought about
doing this or that or whatever it's like
yes yes thank you god I mean this is so
what we've been waiting for and we
didn't get in season and there's almost
a backlash now against like well now
she's just bland and boring and I'm like
well after two seasons of putting up
with her shit I think we're okay
focusing on some of the sidekick no I
don't I don't have a problem I don't
think she is especially when you look at
the first couple episodes where they're
going off and trying to get the
airbenders and they try Tenzin's way
it's nowhere yeah it's like well now
time to try a little tough love and it's
you automatically laugh because you know
what's coming and then she still doesn't
have like the patience there's like you
know what the guy won't be Miss Montez
thank you little twerp ah it's it's
still funny and it's still a character
but she's using her head and she's
thinking and she's warming you know and
she's saying hey how about this she's
been around also these two episodes were
not about her that much to begin with
anyway so the fact that she's
contributing anything from the sidelines
I think is fine I don't have an issue
with it like I I don't know
like sometimes this poor character can't
win it's like oh well now she's too
strong oh well now she's not strong
enough oh well now she's just bland oh
well then it's like what just let her be
hey that's good I think she's fine this
season on yeah I think she's fine I
honestly thought she was fine the first
season I had they started off with her
character in the second season as the
first season that I probably would have
like stuck with it but I probably would
have been okay because it was a
progression it really was just that
second season dip and uh yeah like what
the hell now we've just regressed the
character but yeah I don't have an issue
with it like some people do yeah there's
and it's fine because with these two
episodes I'm saying myself the Lin
beifong stuff I definitely wanted to see
what that was and get that resolved and
then so I like that even though it
wasn't but it's it's still there it
still works
I thought the resolution for giving up
saying good morning that has a little
rush but oh this is weird you yeah I
mean with beifong night the only how's
it going the only thing I can figure is
maybe they're playing up the the
acupuncture you know that it is opening
up so much that maybe that was like have
the big fight rest and then we wake up I
just feel really good like maybe I think
that's what they're playing up because
so much is opening up and then it's such
a rush and then finally when the rest
happens it's you feel genuinely
rested you know like both emotionally
and physically
um and Bolin might be getting some love
yes yes I really love my that's all
we're gonna say about that is what it is
I love when you know he says you know
look at this we're sharing stuff we're
bonding and I was like desmos awkward
yet somehow charming line I feel like
that was almost directed at the audience
like see we can slow down yeah it's it's
strangely enough I was still like okay I
still get it works um and again you know
talking about Korra and you know our
consistencies I like that she picked up
metalbending very quick that's always
been her strength is that with the
exception of airbending she could pick
up everything
really fast you know that was like her
big talent so I like that they're like
well like people really don't pick this
up that quick and she does because she
naturally does have that talent and she
understands the elements much more so
it's I like that it still does play into
different strengths in the airbenders
episode legitimately pretty damn funny
when I wanted to be yeah yeah it had
comedy but it also had like some dramas
Tenzin's trying to overcome all of his
issues trying to teach yeah you know
with that episode I'm saying to myself
as soon as it started I'm like god damn
and I know everything that's gonna
happen in this episode now and I was
sort of annoyed but I so like those
characters I like this world I left
yeah I mean I love what I did the only
thing I was sort of like really nice a
bit saying come on is that tense
annoucer head bokura moment where you go
come on guy you're you're still a
teacher and grant you ever been doing it
for long or what this may people would
be different but the extremes he goes to
on syrup going no you wouldn't go this
far I don't think private pyle what is
your major malfunction of their comedic
episode so and I thought it was actually
really funny it was a it was a good
moment for Jinora I love the concept of
like well how about I send a voicemail
to one of the spirits and then that
spirit will tell another spirit and then
Bumi's just like oh what's that trouble
at the old mill Jinora is in trouble
purple monkey dishwasher like does it
get garbled along the way I thousand
other thing I want to bring up I'm glad
they're spirits again we got yeah how
many spirits are weighing around it even
if they're not doing a ton it's still
like know that they're around though
they're the nervous those flying bison
rustlers I think you pointed out you
know looking at the size of that bison
fur that he's wearing the the lead bad
guy that has to be a baby he killed the
baby
kill the baby bison I'm just looking at
this like yeah cuz no it's like it's not
the size of a big bite say it's like the
actual pattern on the egg it's like
that's a baby pie and then I just i sat
there just staring at it and I just
looked at Doug I'm just like oh well and
they're they're pre cliched and boring I
fell into the cliche gang like literally
that every line of dialogue they had was
an episode of scooby-doo hey where'd you
find these kids and it was snooping
around I will take the width and they're
screwy dog dude looks like but you know
what they're their idiot villains yeah
they're there for an episode and I said
we got a great fight out of and I love
Bumi's moment you know it's like we got
to do this every Bender's stick together
and there's like you quit remember is
like yeah it still came to a nice
resolution and everything did sort of
come into play and I thought that was a
nice with the two brothers I thought
that was a nice or meeting point between
the two of them as well because Bumi is
he is a good leader and he's good at
getting people's attitudes up and
motivating them and I like that there is
but tension has the technique so I like
serve the meeting of the two and though
they're probably gonna work off each
other with that so I thought it was
still good it is just one of those
things where it's like oh I know it's
gonna happen which again for any other
cartoon show every cartoon show grew up
in the 80s you knew Seifer see what was
gonna happen so it's I'm just doing this
by Corrib measures you know it's like
what I know it's early okay but it's the
strongest episode writing-wise it's a
necessary episode I think we needed to
see them being taught at some point and
I think a lot of this just goes back to
the fact that they're creating these as
individual miniseries like I get the
feeling had this been done as a full
freeze three season story arc the
writing on these shows would be a little
stronger but I feel like it's kind of
like okay now we're in miniseries number
three yeah they have issues
because like the right the writing
incident like these past two episodes
particularly the one with um Lin beifong
is tight like I'm just like oh my god
did they could they crammed her entire
backstory in they've got Opel's issues
in there they've got Sue's like
literally I'm just like man they are not
like wasting a minute yeah and it but it
still it's it doesn't feel too rushed
which I'm kind of him no I think it will
be the only thing I felt a little more I
feel like I says well it may fall weeks
off well I'm like a handshake and like I
promise not to kill you next time yeah
yeah that's great everything's yeah I
mean that's a bad guys you know and even
the resolution in the original
airbenders you know did I think today
I've learned that blah blah blah maybe I
realize that it's like yeah okay I mean
we know this drill but you've the full
house
guitar music yeah but it's still it
still works okay enough um because you
do see the progression of Halloween I
did call it was my public Facebook I was
calling this the apology tour because
both episodes have the exact same
formula of resolving an issue all
characters Sunday at the end yeah in
apologize yeah I was wrong no I was
wrong well maybe I need to learn from
this well maybe I need to learn from
this and then let's agree and shake yeah
but it works like it's just way worse
out there I don't have a problem with it
and I thought it was actually
legitimately funny so yeah I thought
they were actually pretty good at so
yeah the comedy is kind of getting
strong again that their reactions are so
great there's a lot of scenes where it's
like a line isn't especially funny but
the reactants are so great but there's
something about this ease in particular
that I think they've had in all the
seasons of Korra but the way to talk
their mouths are always kind of sideways
like this and the tough one I feel a
little bit many Creed's
comedic Lee it looks great if it's
always sort of kind of punker I feel
like the animation is a little different
this time around
it's I don't know why I think it's I
thought it was the same group that was
doing it
well no it's different I don't think
it's one group that does an entire
season I think it's I don't know and so
is this a different this feels different
i I swear to god sometimes I feel like
I'm
watching Justice League or something or
it feels like those DC animated that you
were to ever benders one look bad it's
not bad I don't have a problem with it
it's just for some reason this season
I'm like yeah this animation looks a
little different like they've all kind
of look different actually so far yeah
but it's still I'm still blown away by
those backgrounds I mean like I said
just a little tilt this way it's like
you know upward or downward it's like
you don't need to animate that all you
need is a pretty painting but it's like
they see G that whole thing so the
mountains that you look
three-dimensional and they're turning
just a little bit when the camera pans
over so it's gathers just Oh in public
and the earth Queen what a bitch did she
totally eat the fucking bear or not I
look that's the only bear god
everything's always like a voice bear or
a bunny bear what about the only just
bear that was an endangered species it
was a bear so no I heard that I'm like
holy holy crap like that bear very not
be dead that better be a ruler or an
urban legend and then the other in joke
Tenzin's number-one fan at the school
there is named otaku yeah alright well
played well played no there's definitely
some good good jokes in there so yeah
the humor was definitely straw I thought
that the atmosphere in the environment
was very strong and not not unhappen the
story wise gray we did get a Lin's
backstory which is nice and we saw a
little bit more a talk which is great
but we have an otaku now can we do like
one version that's even creepier and
called him a geeky Komori well as long
as he doesn't be a long series nuts so I
think it's about it's about episodes
yeah what do you see you next one take
care